Il y a près de 30 ans,
mon pays faisait face au besoin de tout rebâtir à partir de rien.
Après des années d'occupation soviétique,
l'Estonie a regagné son indépendance mais nous nous sommes retrouvés sans rien.
Pas d'infrastructure, pas d'administration,
pas de code juridique.
Un chaos organisationnel.
Par nécessité,
les dirigeants étatiques de l'époque ont dû faire des choix audacieux.
Ceux que notre pays pouvait se permettre.
Il y a eu beaucoup d'expérimentation et d'incertitude,
mais aussi un peu de chance,
en particulier dans le fait que nous pouvions compter
sur de brillants visionnaires,
cryptographes et ingénieurs.
Je n'étais qu'une enfant à l'époque.
Aujourd'hui, on dit que nous sommes la société la plus numérique sur Terre.
Je viens d'Estonie
et je déclare mes impôts en ligne depuis 2001.
Nous utilisons l'identité et la signature numériques depuis 2002.
Nous votons en ligne depuis 2005.
Aujourd'hui, presque tout l'éventail des services publics
que vous pouvez imaginer :
l'éducation, la police, la justice, fonder une entreprise,
demander une prestation, consulter son dossier de santé
ou contester une contravention --
tout cela est fait en ligne.
En fait, il est plus simple de vous dire
quelles sont les trois choses que vous ne pouvez pas faire en ligne.
Vous devez vous présenter pour récupérer vos documents d'identité,
vous marier ou divorcer
ou vendre de l'immobilier.
C'est à peu près tout.
Ne vous affolez donc pas
quand je vous dis que, chaque année,
j'ai hâte de commencer à faire ma déclaration d'impôts.
(Rires)
Car tout ce que j'ai à faire,
c'est m'asseoir sur mon canapé avec un portable,
parcourir quelques pages
de données pré-remplies sur mes revenus et déductions
et cliquer sur « Soumettre ».
Après trois minutes,
je connais le montant de ma déclaration de revenus.
C'est une expérience assez gratifiante.
Sans conseiller fiscal,
sans collecte de reçus,
sans calculs.
Ai-je évoqué ne pas m'être rendue à un bureau national
depuis près de sept ans ?
L'une des caractéristiques de la vie moderne
qui n'a plus de raison d'exister,
si l'on considère les possibilités technologiques actuelles,
c'est le labyrinthe de la bureaucratie.
Nous nous en sommes presque complètement débarrassés en Estonie,
dans un effort coordonné par le gouvernement,
qui s'est également numérisé.
Par exemple, le travail des cabinets de ministres dans e-Cabinet
est entièrement sans papier.
L'idée centrale derrière ce développement
est la transformation du rôle de l’État
et la numérisation de la confiance.
Pensez-y.
Dans la plupart des pays, les gens ne font pas confiance à leur gouvernement.
Et en retour, le gouvernement ne leur fait pas confiance.
Toutes les procédures formelles, compliquées et sur papier
sont censées résoudre ce problème.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Elles rendent juste la vie plus compliquée.
Je crois que l'expérience estonienne montre
que la technologie peut être le remède pour retrouver la confiance,
tout en créant un système de prestation efficace, centré sur l'utilisateur
qui répond aux besoins des citoyens.
Nous ne l'avons pas fait en numérisant la bureaucratie telle quelle.
Mais plutôt en s'accordant sur quelques principes communs forts,
en reconcevant les règles et les procédures,
en nous débarrassant des collectes de données inutiles
et des tâches dupliquées
et en devenant ouverts et transparents.
Laissez-moi vous donner un aperçu
de certains des principes clés de conception d'e-Estonie.
Tout d'abord, il est essentiel de garantir la vie privée et la confidentialité
des données et informations.
Cela est réalisé via une identité numérique forte
qui est délivrée par l’État
et compatible avec tous les services.
Chaque Estonien en a une.
Cette identité est doublée d'une signature numérique forte
qui est acceptée, utilisée et a une valeur juridique
à la fois en Estonie et dans l'Union européenne.
Quand le système peut identifier correctement et sûrement qui l'utilise,
après connexion, il offrira l'accès aux données personnelles du citoyen
et à tous les services publics au sein d'un seul outil
et lui permettra d'autoriser n'importe quoi en signant numériquement.
Un second principe, et le plus transformateur,
s'appelle « Une seule fois ».
Cela signifie que l’État ne peut pas demander la même information
plus d'une fois
et ne peut pas la conserver dans plus d'un endroit.
Par exemple,
si vous avez déjà fourni votre certificat de naissance ou de mariage
au registre de la population,
c'est le seul endroit où cette donnée va être détenue.
Et jamais plus aucune autre institution ne vous le demandera.
Une fois seulement est une règle formidable
qui définit toute la structure de la collecte de données dans un pays,
quelles informations sont collectées
et qui est responsable de leur conservation,
en nous assurant d'éviter la centralisation des données,
la duplication des données
et en garantissant qu'elles sont à jour.
Cette approche distribuée évite également le problème
d'un point de défaillance unique.
Mais puisque les données ne peuvent pas être répliquées
ou collectées plus d'une fois,
cela signifie que la conception doit garder à l'esprit
un accès sécurisé et robuste à ces informations à tout moment
pour que l'institution publique puisse offrir un service.
C'est le rôle de la plateforme d'échange de données
appelée « X-Road »
qui est utilisée depuis 2001.
Tout comme une autoroute,
elle connecte les bases de données et registres du secteur public,
les municipalités locales et les entreprises,
organisant un échange de données en temps réel, sécurisé et réglementé,
sauvegardant une trace vérifiable de chaque transfert.
Voici une capture d'écran d'une transmission en direct
montrant toutes les requêtes réalisées sur X-Road
et tous les services qu'il rend possibles.
Et voici une vraie représentation de toutes les connexions
entre les bases de données des secteurs public et privé.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
il n'y a pas de base de données centrale.
La confidentialité et la vie privée sont absolument essentielles.
Mais dans un monde numérique,
la fiabilité et l'intégrité des informations
est cruciale pour les opérations.
Par exemple,
si quelqu'un change votre dossier de santé,
disons vos allergies,
sans votre médecin ou vous-même le sachiez,
un traitement pourrait être mortel.
C'est pourquoi, dans une société numérique,
un système comme le nôtre,
où il n'y a presque pas d'originaux papiers,
il n'y a presque que des originaux numériques,
l'intégrité des données,
les règles d'échange de données, les composants logiciels
et les historiques des événements sont primordiaux.
Nous utilisons une forme de blockchain que nous avons inventée en 2007,
bien avant que la blockchain ne soit à la mode,
pour contrôler et garantir l'intégrité des données en temps réel.
La blockchain est notre auditrice
et une promesse qu'aucun accès aux données
et aucune manipulation des données ne demeurent non consignés.
La propriété des données est un autre principe clé
dans la conception du système.
N'êtes-vous pas inquiets
que les gouvernements, les entreprises technologiques
et d'autres entreprises à travers le monde
affirment que les données collectées à votre sujet sont à eux,
refusent communément de donner accès à ces informations
et échouent souvent à prouver comment elles ont été utilisées
ou partagées avec des tiers ?
Je ne sais pas, pour moi cela semble être une situation plutôt inquiétante.
Le système estonien repose sur le principe
qu'un individu est propriétaire des données collectées à son sujet
et de ce fait, a le droit absolu de savoir quelles informations sont collectées
et qui y a accédé.
A chaque fois qu'un policier, un médecin ou n'importe quel agent public
accède à des informations personnelles d'un citoyen en ligne,
premièrement, il n'y a accès qu'après s'être connecté
et seulement aux informations autorisées pour son travail.
Deuxièmement, à chaque fois qu'une requête est faite,
cela est enregistré dans un historique des événements.
Cet historique détaillé fait partie des services publics de l’État
et permet une vraie transparence,
assurant qu'aucune violation de la vie privée
ne passe inaperçue aux yeux du citoyen.
Bien sûr, ce n'est qu'un résumé simplifié
de tous les principes de conception sur lesquels repose e-Estonie.
Le gouvernement s'organise
pour se préparer à utiliser l'intelligence artificielle
et instaurer une nouvelle génération de services publics --
des services proactifs
qui s'activeraient de façon fluide
d'après les différentes circonstances de vie des gens
comme une naissance, du chômage ou le lancement d'une entreprise.
Bien sûr,
administrer une société numérique sans copie papier
peut être un problème.
Même si nous avons confiance en la robustesse de nos systèmes,
on ne peut jamais être trop prudent après notre expérience en 2007,
lors du premier incident cyber
qui a bloqué des parties de notre réseau,
rendant impossible l'accès aux services durant des heures.
Nous avons survécu.
Mais cet indicent a placé la cybersécurité en tête des priorités,
à la fois en termes de consolidation de la plateforme et de sa sauvegarde.
Comment sauvegarder un système national dans un petit État
où tout est très proche ?
Par exemple, vous pouvez exporter une copie des données
en dehors du territoire national
et sur l'espace extraterritorial d'une ambassade.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons ces ambassades de données
qui détiennent les actifs numériques estoniens essentiels,
garantissant la continuité des opérations,
la protection de nos données
et surtout, notre souveraineté.
Même dans le cas d'une attaque physique sur notre territoire.
Certains d'entre vous pourraient penser :
où sont les inconvénients ?
Passer au numérique
est plus efficace administrativement et, soyons honnêtes, financièrement.
Interagir principalement avec des systèmes informatiques
peut donner l'impression que le facteur humain,
les politiciens élus,
et la participation aux processus démocratiques
sont de moindre importance.
Certaines personnes
se sentent menacées par une technologie omniprésente
pouvant rendre leurs compétences obsolètes.
L'un dans l'autre, malheureusement,
administrer un pays sur une plateforme numérique
ne nous a pas épargnés les luttes de pouvoir politique
et la polarisation au sein de la société,
comme nous l'avons vu lors des dernières élections.
Jusqu'à ce que des êtres humains soient impliqués.
Une dernière question.
Si tout cela ne dépend pas de mon emplacement
et que je peux accéder aux services de partout dans le monde,
pourquoi d'autres ne peuvent pas exploiter certains de ces services,
même s'ils ne résident pas en Estonie ?
Il y a cinq ans,
nous avons lancé une start-up gouvernementale,
le programme e-Residence,
auquel adhèrent actuellement des dizaines de milliers de personnes.
Ce sont des hommes et femmes d'affaires venus de 136 pays différents,
qui créent leur entreprise numériquement,
qui ont accès à leur banque en ligne
et qui dirigent leur entreprise virtuellement via la plateforme e-Estonie,
dans le cadre légal de l'Union européenne,
en utilisant une carte d'identité électronique similaire à la mienne
et tout cela depuis n'importe où dans le monde.
Le système estonien ne dépend pas de votre emplacement
et est centré sur l'utilisateur.
Il priorise l'inclusivité, l'ouverture et la fiabilité.
Il place en son cœur la sécurité et la transparence.
Et les données dans les mains de leur propriétaire légitime :
la personne à laquelle elles font référence.
Ne me croyez pas sur parole.
Essayez.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)